hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i've write content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about the flat iron
school
application and how to really ace it and
make sure that
you get admitted into this coding
bootcamp so let's get into it
the first step in the application
process was really just filling out that
general application i say application
loosely because to me it was more of an
interest form where you shared your name
and why you're interested maybe wrote a
couple of
short answers for why you're interested
and
really that was it didn't really take
more than 30 minutes if that
so after filling this out i remember
getting
immediate access to some pre-work of
theirs
just some very um basic things regarding
i believe it was
ruby that was the main focus at the time
i applied
in may of 2020 and so getting just
some basic pre-work in and really
getting that
first look into what a day as a flat
iron school student would
look like within 24 to 48 hours though
of filling my you know application or
interest form
i remember receiving a call or an
email from somebody in admissions i i
call admissions maybe there's a
different non-technical name
but yes from admissions from the
administration office
trying to see if you would like to join
their programs
and in this conversation i expressed
interest
and we set up an interview this
interview occurred about one week
i want to say after submitting that
application or
after that initial person reached
out to me so one week to 10 days after
the application itself
and in this really what they want to see
is that you are passionate about this
career switch
your passion about coding and also you
have
done some of the work yourself they
don't want to let people in
who have never coded anything before
never
typed hello world before and are saying
oh yeah i'm going to do x y and z for x
amount of months no
they want people who are passionate
because this is a hard
journey and truly the only thing that
will get you through it is
passion i mean that there's it is
passion and love
for what you're doing and that really
being what
carries you through that finish line so
they want people who have practiced
alone already and so for me i had
only really done html and css work and
so i had expressed to them
that i started building static sites
just different projects
and started trying to see what maybe
family members and friends would
want out of a site whether they have a
small business or
they have a hobby that they want some
type of landing page for
and i shared that and i shared this is
where i'm supposed to be i loved coding
in
you know this aspect and i've been also
learning on udemy and codecademy
and i really am looking for you guys to
provide me that robust structure of
learning and they love that's really
really
what they want to see after this
i heard back from them if i was going to
get a second interview i wanted to say
just
at most three days after that initial
interview and so the second interview
was
more of a technical interview where you
did
pair programming with one of their
instructors one of their program leaders
etc
and this was nerve wracking oh my
goodness this was nerve-wracking
and so that is why you had access to
pre-work
because they needed you to go through
that material
get to a certain point of that material
and then
provide the solution that that chapter
asked for provide those solutions to the
person
on the other side of the screen
and oh i
it's rough it's rough um not even
because you know they're
you know mean or hard or anything well
it was kind of for me hard
you know but it was more rough because
i have never done this you know what i
mean like i feel like if you're watching
this video you've never really done
things like this before and so that's
what made it the most
difficult now the pre-work was in
ruby and so did about
a week's worth i believe the next
interview had been scheduled for
about 10 days after my initial interview
i really wanted
to have enough time to go through all of
it i was really devoting everything to
it
the administrator was flexible it was
really dependent on
how quickly you wanted to go to the boot
camp do you want to be in the
next cohort or can you wait a month two
months three months
so that really determined your interview
schedule
and your application cycle schedule so
for the next
10 days i'm going through that pre-work
going through the questions to
really try to make these solutions and
everything and
preparing for this interview now
how did i prepare one of the things i
did to prepare
was after i developed what i saw you
know as the solution
i looked at my code and tried to
determine how i would make it better
i didn't make it better because then if
they asked me how do i make it better
well i already made it better
you should have seen it yesterday and so
i didn't make it better
but i tried to determine how i would
make it better because
i had done some research and seen that
that is a question they'll
often ask so try to see how i would make
it better
and this is so important and made sure
i could talk about what i just created
a lot of times this sounds so simple
y'all a lot of times
you create something and it just like
works
and someone asks you okay how
did you go about doing this explain this
to me you have no
idea sir i just hit my computer on the
side
and it worked i don't know what to tell
you so
it's really important for you to really
understand
why the things work the way they do
and how you would explain this to a
five-year-old a six-year-old there's a
saying if you can't explain it to a
first grader
you don't know it well enough and so
really making sure you could
truly explain it line by line and
yes go through that solution with them
and also explain
why you chose certain you know variables
or certain
iterations or x y and z why you chose
the solution
or the way about getting to the solution
that you did now we are at the technical
interview
and it was just like i had prepared it
was
go through your code explain it to me
and how could you make it better now
the part that you know was rough
was rough for me was the pair
programming part the reason they do this
is because they want to
see that you are teachable that you
understand
the jargon when they say x y and z that
you can
easily understand and follow along
because
yes coding bootcamp is there to teach
you but
you're going so fast they need to know
you come with something
something they need to know you have
something
there to begin with because if you don't
have certain things certain qualities
certain skills
you are going to just fall behind so
quickly within weeks you'll be just
gone so that's why they do this they
want to make sure that you are
ready for this step if not then maybe
take
a few more weeks months going through
all this and come back to us
but that is why they do that especially
that pair programming part
and so going through that pair
programming part
it was really just following along with
what
the person on the other side of the
screen was
wanting to see um
she would ask oh i don't even know she
would ask
oh let's create this type of innumerable
and i'd need to quickly remember
what an innumerable was and then go
through all of that
and so being able to
semi quickly follow along do the things
that
they ask for and show that you are
good enough good enough to be
here to be in this boot camp right now
not
in general i'm not saying that there are
people not good enough but some people
you need more time if you just applied
yesterday in your
technical interviews two days from now
you're probably not very ready and so
you want to just make sure that you are
ready to start this process and so
just going through that and then closing
my laptop
and being like lord please not gonna lie
all i stumbled i stumbled on that
pair programming part i truly and it's
probably why i can't even remember it
that well because i just blacked out
i could not i was
terrified when i hung up and i had to
wait
to see my fate because i was like
man i i stumbled there it was just that
thing of not being sure of what she
was asking for me and really just being
so
hesitant and feeling like she expects me
to know that
and i do not so so it was very
you know iffy on for me but i
received a call later that day from the
initial
administrator and they said i
was in that i got a
great score and that they would love to
have me in their next cohort
and so overall that really is
that cycle you can expect
with fire school i don't know how it is
with other boot camps so i really
can't proclaim anything i apologize
after getting accepted that was when i
needed to
understand how i'm going to pay for this
oh y'all it was eighteen thousand
dollars when i went oh my gosh
i need to figure out how i was gonna pay
for this who was gonna pay for it
where it was coming from and so i looked
at there many
different well i say many it was not
many it was three i looked at the three
different options i had
one was getting a loan
one was paying cash my part
and one was an income share agreement
which i
i had been looking at different boot
camps at the time
and ultimately i chose flying school
because one
of the brand name i know they have a
strong brand name
but also because they had the income
share agreement
the income share agreement what it is
overall
was the school would relieve me of
any payment until i got
a job and then when i got a job i would
have to pay
about 10 of my income every single month
until 10 of my monthly income every
single month
until i paid back the 18 000.
i also ended up getting a 3 000
scholarship meant to increase
accessibility for women and people of
color and so
i received that scholarship as well and
so my total got brought down to 15 000
and with the 15 000 i didn't have to pay
the 500
deposit fee which you had to do to
secure your spot for the
cohort you want to be in and so
after you get accepted things went
pretty quickly
because you had to figure out how you're
going to pay for it and
find out how you're going to put this
deposit in and y'all i did not have 500
yo i did not have 50 i i did not have
so so i was very very happy when i saw i
got the scholarship
and the administrator is the one who
told me about that she sent me the link
and i filled it out that day and by
the next day i found out i had received
it
and so they have very quick turnaround
and so decided to go for the income
share agreement as well
i've heard from some of y'all that they
don't
offer it anymore please let me know in
the comments if
they don't that would be tragic if they
don't because to be honest i wouldn't
have been able to go i
truly truly would not have been able to
go if they didn't have the income share
agreement so someone out there
for from flatiron is watching this
please get that back because it really
helps more people get on this career
path
but anyway received that income share
agreement received that
scholarship so now i felt relief
but that was very fleeting because now i
had about three weeks to go through
the rest of that pre-work material you
still have to go through the pre-work
so that you're prepared on day one
because y'all
you get on day one boom like
write x y z code this like it is
quick quick quick and so you have about
i believe it was about 100 hours of
pre-work we had
to do before
yeah before our first day and so for the
next three to four weeks that was a big
focus of
mine but overall there we go and then
you know if this is your first video of
mine then you can go on to
my flatiron school experience video
where i talk about
my time at flatiron but that's what the
application
process looks like please subscribe if
you like this video please leave a like
and yeah i hope this was informative
i hope it was informative but thank you
so much for watching this and i'll see
y'all later bye